and not just
expendable commodities so you could just
isn't it isn't it crazy how men built
the world for us and then we [ __ ] on
them as a thank you that's what i'm
saying it is crazy i think i i find it
incredibly incredibly sad
incredibly sad because we're supposed to
be coming together as as as people who
who should love each other and and
spread joy rather than literally it's
hate hate and anger all the time and i
see all these people and i'm just like
why do you like all this drama by the
way why do you want to come home your
man's tired and then you're gonna i
don't know yell at them because oh i'm
tired and he put his foot up on the
table
you know something really silly and why
can't you just have an adult
conversation and respect the fact that
hey he's tired too and yes okay we maybe
there are things that needs ironing out
but why don't we have an adult
conversation why do you have to raise
your voice and be disrespectful to each
other yeah um did you see did you guys
see that video it was a tick tock video
and it went pretty viral of this uh
military wife
and um
she were bitching her husband trying to
uh get him to do the laundry and this is
while he was like
off for like i don't know i don't know
how it works in the us but it's like the
rougher two the two weeks on for a
certain period of time but it was off
and um she was like complaining about
him doing the laundry
well you know when he's on duty
he's risking his life even in training
you know because training deaths happen
a lot
so like it's just mad to me that that's
even like
a thing wait so she filmed it i'm sorry
oh yeah yeah no i saw that yeah
and then
they ended up getting divorced and did
they i thought they did
i hope you're right
that guy deserves so much better yeah
can i just point out what the problem is
it's not even the fact that she did it
it's the fact that it's even public
um men deserve resp mentors
no no no no no no i'm not saying that
that's not even the worst bit that's
what i'm saying the fact that she made
it public she's literally publicly
humiliating this poor man i'm sorry if
you have a problem be an adult talk to
each other
as adults you trying to air your dirty
laundry literally to other people so if
you girls do this all the time i see it
and it's i hate it they they will they
will go to their friends they hang out
together and then all of a sudden
they're going to say oh my god what's
the problem with the man they're like
can't they just like put like their
trousers like can i just put it in the
basket i even got a really nice basket
it's like there i put it in the spot
where he drops it and and he just
wouldn't do it i don't get it like
what's wrong with him and i'm just like
why are you doing this to him um so
question let's go around
what are your personal standards
yeah so what would you expect from a
woman and then what would you guys
expect from a man like minimum
requirements to date them well i'd say
right now i can't expect much um but i
am you know in the process as i said i'm
young and uh
i do plan on you know making six figures
eventually i got the six foot down
unlock and i think i'm pretty cute so
eventually i'll have the standard set in
place but right now i'm focused on on my
career but i do have
you know anticipations for my standards
such as um
you know submission like
um and
just
peace of mind someone who can offer me
peace of mind you know someone that's
not always in my life
you did this wrong i don't want that
you know like if i'm
if i'm willing to provide right um and
be the breadwinner
then
um if she wants to work fine but
obviously the the common
thing is do you prefer she stays home
yes but like if she should do it if she
doesn't want to work if she does want to
work right everyone says you need a you
need the masculine trait to work right
um especially in a career so
but like when she gets home she drops
that masculinity at the door
because i'm not i'm not competing in my
own household i gotta compete with other
men out in the world to look at me six
foot tattoos beard
and then they just like assume i'm top
dog and then com competition time i
don't know if that's more of a you thing
so like because i'm a youth
but uh
yeah it's certainly what i'm
experiencing right now so i definitely
do not want to have that in the
household that i'm paying for
yeah i agree i think for me my woman
must offer peace man because i know how
much i work i know how to when i come
home i want her that my household to be
my safe space to be you know peaceful
and relaxed and also
i think the most number one thing is
she's gotta be she's gotta be feminine
she has to be able to submit
um she has to be family oriented because
i don't have kids yet but that's that's
the main goal i want to have kids i want
her to be a family based person um
preach yeah that's it is that how your
girl is now yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
she's respected
so um i do want
in my terms i do want a a man who
respects me
i want a masculine man so
exactly what you guys are saying a man
who has
great achievements he has a path he's
ready to work on himself to make himself
better and he also respects me and
someone that i will feel proud of and i
would want to
nurt give him the love and support as
you said as a woman and be his his
number one fan i want to be his home i
want to be the person that he can come
to me
where everyone else will be a bit on
guard and he will feel comfortable to
just drop it a little bit because i am
his home so what what does he have to
have because you're kind of describing
what you want to be for him but the
question was like what what does he have
to be in order to get that so for me
it's rather than the do you have a
height requirement no no he could be
short at five foot i dated a man that
was shorter than me before for two years
okay
i'm not i will say this i'm not very
normal but
for me i have learned the value of the
true value of a person isn't their
exterior it's it's their insides it's
their personalities it's whether they
fit me so for example one of the things
because i did a personality test of
jordan peterson okay and one of the
things he looks at is agreeableness
and one of my criterias i want for my
man is i want him to be
less agreeable than me
why because
i am quite agreeable and i'm always
worrying that maybe i might step on
someone's toes but someone who's less
agreeable is not going to be as easily
uh you know like offended so i like that
i don't have to feel
you know like can i tell you are you
going to get offended so for example so
you want to just so
okay this is like kind of broad so i
just i want to be a little bit more
specific so you want someone
disagreeable what else
so what's some more disagreeable does he
have stateful
i would like him to be um from a
skill set knowledge income level equal
to me okay which is roughly
well i'm um
i earn around 3 000 a month so maybe
something like that okay
is there anything else so you want
roughly like at your income or more
would you ever submit to a guy that
makes less than you
yes because it's not about the now
people are changing no no he he's
staying at that it's not build a man so
he's no no no no no no no it's not i'm
not saying that
i'm trying to build him
but this is the thing like just because
a man may not be as good now doesn't
mean he isn't late
it's about realizing but i'm saying like
a lot of times like girls we try to
build a man like we go to build-a-bear
but
but guys like like i don't know
what i'm saying i'm saying like when you
said it's not about the now it's about
the later that's implying that you're
you would want him to his income to
increase but i'm saying like most guys
kind of are where they're at
especially like you said you're 34.
so if a guy is 35 like 35 like i'd
imagine you want roughly your age or
older so
so for me that's the thing like so for
me
i
honestly
all i'm gonna say is i've realized that
the physical shell of things
they're not as important as peace and
the the person that's inside does that
come of age though did you realize that
100 right this is and this is the thing
like this is something i've learned this
is something that i internalized i had
to go i was single for i've been single
still single for a long time because
guess what i needed to work on myself
like if i'm broken and i'm not in the
right frame of mind i'm going to end up
damaging another person i don't want
that
if i'm not ready then i'm going to work
on myself and to be honest like yes
i'll be it's difficult to give you a
figure but the people with the six
figures who are getting all these girls
and driving lambos i don't want them
either is is monogamy a requirement for
you
for me yes okay do you feel like that's
a fair deal for a guy
um because he's not getting you for your
best years
that depends on what the man wants so
i'm saying like long term like i i'm and
this is going for like me too none of us
are virgins anymore so i think like men
value purity and youth right and they're
not getting that anymore so do you think
it's a fair deal for men when they're
not getting that to be monogamous to us
to comprise on their mating strategy
when we don't fulfill theirs because
we're not virgins anymore
because i feel like when you talk about
something and saying that that's the
only reason you have value i think
that's wrong because i think it's that
it's not i'm not saying that's the only
reason you have value i'm talking about
your value in the dating market
and like like results are harsh the
world's harsh
and like the truth is modern women are
less pure than they've ever been and
we're older than we've ever been so i'm
asking do you think that's a fair deal
for men when they have to be more and
more less
if a man is going to look at me and say
that the only value i come i can bring
to the table is because of my no i
didn't say the only value so i'm not
saying that's the only value like you
seem like a smart girl i know you have
more than just that but i'm saying in
the dating market like this is what it
starts with and it's harsh but it's
reality
but
sorry i'm just
but you're saying we're going with age
and we're going with well it's like men
men value purity and youth so they like
young virgins that's the that's the
ideal just like our ideal is like rich
men right but i'm saying now in today's
day and age like women have higher
standards than ever but bring less to
the table to than ever we're older we've
slept with more people and we have less
loyalty because we're the ones leaving
them
so is it a fair deal yeah so i'm saying
do you think that's a fair deal for men
i think it generally depends on the
person i'm sorry i can't answer that
question
okay go ahead what are your requirements
for a guy uh that he's aware of the the
traditional gender roles okay
like and i expect that and he expects
that from me
and reciprocity and i think respect is
and i don't expect him just to respect
me just like that because i'm a woman i
think he needs to get to know me
and um the relationship has to be
reciprocal and
i i'm 28 and i don't
i actually want him to be politicist
i can speak so much about it they're
calling you an indian queen right now oh
god